sion ouvrant donc ce journal avec au
portugal devant des centaines de
milliers de fidèles la révélation du
troisième secret de fatima le vatican a
finalement décidé de dévoiler
l'intégralité du message que la vierge
aurait annoncé aux jeunes bergers il ya
plus de 80 ans mettant ainsi un terme ou
aux hypothèses les plus folles
quelques heures auparavant jean paul ii
avait célébré la cérémonie de
béatification
entouré par la ferveur et la piété des
pèlerins en ce 13 mai jour hautement
symbolique puisque le saint père avait
échappé à la mort lors d'un attentat en
80 sur place dans un vieil spéciaux
isabelle steiss dominique merlin depuis
longtemps sur lucie partage le secret
avec jean paul ii à 93 ans elle est
l'unique survivante des trois petits
bergers
et c'est à elle que la vierge aurait
confié ses prophéties en 1917 dont le
fameux troisième secret que sur lucie
devenu carmélites avait transmis au
vatican en 1950
et c'est devant des milliers de fidèles
qui assistaient à fatima à la
béatification de jacinthes et françois
que le pape a enfin décidé de lever le
mystère sur la dernière vision de la
vierge quelques la raconter sur lui si
un évêque vêtus de blanc et qui tombe à
terre sous les coups d'une arme à feu un
secret que jean paul ii connaissez au
moment de l'attentât en 1981 je me
rappelle que un jour après les
les associations de roms
il a l'âme il était alors dans notre
pays à l'hôpital il a demandé de le
les documents pour les lille encore une
fois et c'est à ce moment là qu'il s'est
rendu compte que cette ce message le
concerné lui personnellement oui c'est
sûr ça c'est seniors filles 1 et sage
d'autant plus symbolique 19 ans jour
pour jour après l'attentât de la place
saint pierre jean paul ii est convaincu
que c'est la vierge qui lui a sauvé la
vie
un des projectiles et d'ailleurs serti
dans la couronne aujourd'hui à fatima le
pape l'a une nouvelle fois à remercier
tout comme il a rendu un vibrant hommage
aux petits bergers
bienheureux messages et des prophéties
de la vierge
c'est sans doute en raison de sa
profonde dévotion à la vierge que jean
paul ii a finalement choisi de lever le
mystère autour du fameux troisième
secret ici même à fatima et 19 ans jour
pour jour après l'attentât de la place
saint-pierre le vatican devrait
maintenant publier le message dans les
jours qui viennent à l'attention des
fidèles depuis ce matin